[Musique]
7h du matin dans la réserve de 10 à 400
km d'abidjan à chaque départ de safari
le visage de daouda est fermé depuis 22
ans toujours la même inquiétude que les
visiteurs ne puisse pas découvrir des
animaux du parc c'est quand même à la
chasse c'est pas tout quand ce dernier
lui rapidement
une espèce d'antilope disparu du paysage
ivoirien qui se laisse approcher en
famille
[Applaudissements]
le propre des façades le bus
dans les sièges ne pas tacher ou
franco ivoirienne installée à abidjan
inès fois ces animaux pour la première
fois en côte d'ivoire
de trésors naturels qu'on n'exploite pas
du tout quand on parle de taudis pas les
gens pensent directement aux choses les
plus populaires le cacao de la noix de
cajou et en fait non on a aussi des
choses comme ça
si l'existence d'un safari a de quoi
surprendre en côte d'ivoire c'est en
raison de la déforestation massive qui a
touché le pays 90% des forêts
ivoiriennes ont disparu ces 60 dernières
années et avec elle l'essentiel de la
faune à l'origine de ce projet de
conservation un chef d'entreprise franco
ivoirien qui a construit cet hôtel
inspiré des complexes touristiques
sud-africain sa conviction que c'est
grâce au tourisme animalier que la
conservation animal pourra trouver des
financements
pourquoi pas de l'ouest lors de la
création du parc à la fin des années 90
les animaux avaient déserté la forêt de
l'arrivée annecy après 22 ans de
conservation la faune revient
progressivement mais la diversité
animale est loin d'être entièrement
rétablie à l'image d'une espèce menacée
d'extinction
hier omniprésente en côte d'ivoire à 13
ans éléphants ahmed vite ici en
semi-liberté dans un espace de 20
hectares
après une période plus mouvementée
il s'est retrouvé dans la village aux
environs est en train de casser les
champs et on l'a capturé pour l'angoissé
dans sa zone pour qu'on puisse le
protéger lui permettre d'avoir la
décence la disparition des pachydermes
en côte d'ivoire alarme la communauté
scientifique depuis des décennies il ya
40 ans 3000 éléphants était sur nos
territoires ils sont environ 200
aujourd'hui
daouda a connu l'époque où l'on pouvait
on croisait à l'état naturel
le parc permet d'empêcher les conflits
entre les hommes et des animaux mais
l'éloignement des habitations ne suffit
pas à les protéger aujourd'hui le
braconnage reste sans doute la première
menace sur les bêtes de la réserve dit l
ennemi principal des gardes chargés de
surveiller la zone qui ne sortent jamais
sans leur fusil
en parlant avec deux bras connaît on
sait jamais face à lui on le voit
qu'elle ait said a agi ainsi nous aide
comme ça moi aussi voilà je me défendre
avec en période sèche la forêt de vian
praticable et les incursions des
braconniers nombreuses des fois quand ce
l'oeuvre on prend la voix on voit la
trace des genres nous on a notre
chaussure que reconnaissante au nom si
on voit des chaussures différence c'est
qu'elle a montré un chat sait où des
fois aussi on attend coude et physique
est comme ça andré recruté parmi les
habitants des villages voisins les
gardes sont souvent eux mêmes d'anciens
chasseurs aujourd'hui ils sont plus
d'une trentaine à se relayer pour
surveiller les quarante et un mille
hectares de la réserve jour et nuit
le terreau est vraiment compliquée avant
pour voir un seul animal ici il faut
taper des deux mois il avait plein des
chats c'est plein de charbonnier la boue
vieux si les éleveurs de voeux et les
charbonniers en quête de bois de chauffe
ont bien cesser d'entrer dans la réserve
ce sont désormais les chercheurs d'or
qui viennent dans polluer les eaux ce
soir là quatre personnes sont
appréhendées sur un site d'orpaillage
louis diakité vient à leur rencontre
[Musique]
ces jeunes gens ont été arrêtés par des
soldats de l'office ivoirien des parcs
et réserves présent ponctuellement sur
place c'est de pire en pire là on a on a
vu ces dernières années vraiment une
croissance je dirais de l'orpaillage
illicites ça c'est alors on était déjà
avec les braconniers en avait fort à
faire mais maintenant avec les
orpailleurs c'est encore encore pire les
menaces sur l'environnement sont énormes
70 % de nos dépenses et pour la
protection de l'environnement pour faire
face à ces menaces une barrière
électrifiée 200 km sera construite
autour de la réserve la défense de la
faune en côte d'ivoire est une bataille
est loin d'être terminée